oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants bush
hu
on veut pas pas pu tous vos buts aux
folles petit propos elle bien gai ce
soir dans noces monsieur fun où j'oublie
c'est la fin papa est bien bonne fête à
tous les tapas quel dommage que je ne
suis pas à pas ah bon les seuls bons
tampons petit papa c'est toujours 8 a
fait au petit papa au oublier la suite
au froid raison aux rideaux tu as plutôt
en retard ou le souhaitait ce matin ça
c'est à notre papa est un lien fred
étape beau cadeau moi je viens faire une
tête
rafa était moi je vais en faire tu l'as
rien donné ni colas aussi qu l'embrasser
très fort et je le dis bones est papa il
était bien content moi je l'embrassé
nous et papa il était si heureux qui m'a
donné à bout pu la faire et un maillot
terre et manche et non un gros pull over
ya un petit bikini pour aller à la mer
petits veinards vous avez des cas du
wind annoncé on part très bientôt à la
haye
vacances et toi ne nous tue pas en
vacances j'ai bien peur que le marchand
de sable ne projette encore un long
voyage dans un pays lointain pour
maintenance ont été créés à tous les
yeux des bacs à tasca bonsu aux enfants
je vous écrirai ses premiers l'ont dit
le tard au dodo lé petit van hove
on y va on est sage nos ses cheveux
brook
oh
bonne nuit gros nounours à demain bonne
nuit
mais petit long
[Musique]
fais mon bien les paupières
on soit
apparemment
j'ai talus mieux
rochus le petit
ils en font j'ouvre la fenêtre je sors
ce au bruit
les enfants peu
trop
sont endormis
jo
prends
on y chante
l'eau
joe cole
mon show man
nico
après 2
je
bonjour
et partout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
demain les enfants qui est encore une
fois bonne fête à tous les papas bonnes
feuilles papa allons en route mon bon
nounours bonne nuit les petits
embrasser bien fort votre papa et votre
maman est allée vite vous coucher bonne
nuit
[Musique]
oui
à
[Musique]